welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Ghostbusters Frozen Empire a
followup to 2021 Ghostbusters afterlife
that introduced us to the descendants of
Egon Spangler and reunited them with
heral reis's Ghost and now everybody's
been dragged back into the big city with
the original cast including dickas to
stop the second Ice Age all this is
coming March 22nd let's break down this
trailer shot by shot for all the Easter
eggs the callbacks and an answer to the
question of whether Rick Moranis Lewis
Tully could be hiding in the trailer hey
come hang out with new rock stars live
in Los Angeles on February 15th at brain
dead Studios our last live show was a
lot of fun and we got to talk with you
guys on the other side of the Super Bowl
about Deadpool 3 how weird Madame Webb
is going to be and other crazy stuff
that you never get to see us do here on
YouTube tickets are still available Link
in the description okay let's break down
this trailer but in this video we are
going to look at shots from both the
North American version of the trailer
and the international trailer if you
like me found the north americ trailer
to be kind of hard to follow more center
around the jokes and the memberberries
with weird dialogue and the cuts just
kind of happening illogically definitely
definitely watch international trailer
because what this movie is trying to do
makes a lot more sense if you watch that
okay this trailer opens with the Ecto
one swerving down Fifth Avenue in
Manhattan this is on Fifth between 19th
and 20th and while you cannot see it
that well here that is the Empire State
Building in the background on the left
and looking at the ector one you will
notice right away that roof has now been
augmented with this Dome this contains
the Drone powerered ghost trap that we
will see later inside the car is Egon
spangler's family his daughter cie
Spangler kri and her kids egon's
grandkids Trevor Finn wolfart and Phoebe
Mckenna Grace and their former teacher
and seismologist Gary guerson Paul Rudd
it looks like they all have Ghostbusters
jumpsuits with Spangler on the patch but
Gary got his own patch with groon which
is a mouthful of letters to fit on an
embroidered patch but they made it work
quick recap from Ghostbusters afterlife
Phoebe and Trevor found the Ecto one and
Egon Somerville Oklahoma home along with
all of his old gear but a nearby old Min
shaft owned by The shandor Mining
Company shandor of course was the name
of the leader of the gozerian cult
referenced in the 19 4 film this m shaft
has a temple that Egon had rigged to
stop goer from escaping from a portal
but goer breaks free the family uses
egon's gear to stop Gozer and they get
an assist from the OG crew Peter vanman
Ray stance and Winston zamore along with
the help of the ghost of Egon Spangler
himself director Jason wrightman son of
Ghostbusters director Ivan wman
recreated the likeness of the late
Herald Ramis with the visual effects
team at the moving picture company Bob
gunton and Ivan wman actually did the
physical performance and it was done
reportedly with the blessing of RIS
family since then zag aftera has
actually won new rules after their 2023
strike mandating that consent from the
performer must be obtained to create AI
replicas and if the actor is deceased
the production must get consent from
quote an authorized representative or
the union I have some personal thoughts
about this that I will get to at the end
of this breakdown but in the closing
minutes of the 2021 film Peter venman
returned to New York where we learned
that he was married to Dana Barrett
Sigourney Weaver and in a post credit
scene Winston meets with Janine he gives
her the key that she had given to Egon
spanker before the final battle of the
1984 film and Winston starts talking
about his history with the crew how he
covers the rent at Ray's bookstore and
his success growing his company zedor
Industries I started this business with
one
employee and I'm grown it into a
thriving Global
Enterprise I may be a
businessman but I will always be a
Ghostbuster and then Winston Returns the
ector one to the old Ghostbusters
firehouse and in the basement a light on
the Ecto containment unit flashes red
that red flash may be a sign of the
villainous ghost of this movie gaka so
in this movie William Eon returns as
Walter pek you remember him that's the
EPA inspector from the 1984 film who
tried to shut down the Ghostbusters and
stupidly shut off their containment unit
peeg also showed up in an episode of The
Real Ghostbusters animated series big
trouble with little Slimer and in the
Ghostbusters video game when he led the
Paranormal contracts oversight
commission and it's just kind of a
recurring tradition that government
oversight is just the natural enemy of
the Ghostbusters it's kind of why we
love the Ghostbusters they're
workingclass Heroes and hey hey in the
real world the US Supreme Court is
probably going to reverse the Chevron
Rule and completely gut Federal agency's
regulatory Powers so no wonder dickas is
so pissed off PC says I've been waiting
40 years for this they called themselves
Ghostbusters according to these hacks
they saved the world no eyewitnesses I
find what he's saying to be kind of
weird because in the 1989 sequel
Ghostbusters 2 the Ghostbusters were
sued for property damage at the wazu
they're put out of business from
investigating the Paranormal at all they
were forced make money from birthday
parties and raise a cult bookstore so
yeah the Ghostbusters were already
properly discredited 35 years ago I also
don't know why PC says that there were
no eyewitnesses to what they did as
everyone in New York could see the state
Puff Marshmallow Man and even LS Tully
testified that he got turned into a dog
and the Ghostbusters saved him but I
guess that peek is saying that the state
puff man exploded like on his own and
that Lewis is a liar really I just think
that dickas probably feels like he never
got his name cleared after they called
him dickas in the 1984 incident and for
40 years he has just feared that the
city might call all upon them again for
some of their which definitely
seems to be the case here as Winston
through his business's success has put
the Ghostbusters back in business we
dissolve from the Spangler family in the
acto one to Ray and Winston in the acto
one in the scene in the 1984 film this
is a scene where Ray quoted the
forboding passage from The Book of
Revelation as they were driving over the
bridge and I looked as he opened the
Sixth Seal and behold there was a great
earthquake and the sun became as black
as sackcloth and the moon became his
blood and the Seas boiled and the skies
fell Judgment Day
we see shots in these opening parts of
Phoebe and Trevor going through egon's
old boxes you'll notice there's one
that's labeled Ghostbusters artwork and
then we see peek grilling the Spangler
family you have a minor hanging out the
side of a moving vehicle firing a laser
gun indiscriminately has a proton back
it's completely safe I wouldn't say
completely safe the Ghostbusters are
finished right well overruled
sustained thank you so PC's office here
makes it look as though he might now be
the mayor of New York it's definitely a
different office office in the mayor's
office from the 1984 film but there is
the flag of New York City in the
background there he's wearing the black
vest and red tie that the mayor wore in
1984 I guess it'd be kind of weird for
an EPA agent to climb the ranks of New
York City's politics to become the mayor
especially if he was so publicly anti-
Ghostbusters and you got to imagine
someone from the EPA is going to be
really pissed off when the summertime is
suddenly plagued with an ice storm
something that's just going to make his
job a lot harder to explain global
warming now the family's in trouble
because they were chasing down this blue
Serpentine goat with these Oozy Jaws we
see this later in the trailer and in the
international version Phoebe on the side
chair using the proton pack to lasso it
and Trevor piloting that drone operated
trap to catch it under that Dome it even
has a drone landing pad on the roof of
the actor one very cool and yes very
clearly designed to sell more toys in
Ray's occult book store he reads his
book titled strange but true the world's
weirdest newspaper stories and Kamal
Nani plays someone named Nadim rasat and
he tries to sell this mysterious orb to
Ray if you listen closely to this moment
in this trailer you can actually hear
some Whispering mixed into the audio is
Ray listed
up the international version of the
trailer shows this long line of
eccentric folks with creepy objects
Dolls There's a saxophone they're all
trying to sell these possessed
possessions to Ray for top dollar and I
like how on the outside of the store you
can see that there's live music that
plays at Ray's bookstore I imagine it's
probably the Blues Brothers I also like
how in an overhead shot he is definitely
inspecting this orb with a pke meter
because of course he is the
international trailer also shows Winston
introducing the family to his new
paranormal Research Center I assume this
is in the basic of the firehouse welcome
to the new paranormal Research Center
you just let ghosts hang out in here
we've spent 40 years traveling there now
we can study them and working for
Winston zore Industries include celesto
Conor returning as lucky Domingo from
Somerville Oklahoma in the first film
and newcomer British comedian James
icter as a character named Lars pinfield
Lars has been described as an Egon
Spangler type he oversees the technology
for this company and I love how these
texts all wear Black jumpsuits with the
no ghost patch but the red circle of the
logo is in the shape of a gear also
notice how the red Ecto containment unit
is a lot bigger now when Winston shows
it off previously it was like the size
of a fuse box now it has taken up the
entire wall so it's just a little sign
of how things have escalated in the
North American Trailer Lars and lucky
experiment with this orb and Lars is
hand freezes over it when he tries to
touch it right before his hand touches
it though notice how specific pieces of
this orb stick out and then drop back
into place I think it's kind of like a
spherical Rubik's Cube where the runes
twist around to form into a new
alignment the miniature stay puffed
marshmallow return in this film first
seen in the Oklahoma Superstore
activating from a bag of marshmallows as
they did before these guys just
gleefully mutilate themselves in each
other one just whips candy into the
other's mouth they mush up their arms in
a pencil sharpener meanwhile there's
another one with a pencil in the
background that just looks like it's
impaled in his chest the international
trailer shows one having been flattened
completely why do they do this I assume
it's because for them existence is pain
and doing this to themselves and each
other is the only way they can relieve
that pain now February 15th new root
stars is putting up another live show in
Los Angeles at brain dead Studios at
these new Rockstar live shows we cover
the latest releases we have some special
guests we have a great time geeking out
with you in the audience in person and
we get to do stuff that we never get to
do here on YouTube the last one of these
we did in November it's just been a
complete blast it's just been amazing to
meet all of you so we want to do another
one of these brain dead Studios is this
awesome old school single Screen Theater
they have a beer garden they have some
really cool merch so if you're in Los
Angeles we would love to see you there
February 15th is going to be days after
the Super Bowl and a day after the of
Madam web so we're going to have so much
to talk about so much to theorize on and
so much to just recover from so let's do
it together you can get a ticket by
clicking the link in the description or
by heading to dice.fm and searching for
new rock stars tickets are limited so
grab yours now we'll see you in person
on February 15th Paton o plays a new
character Dr Hubert wartski who seems to
be some kind of expert in history of the
artifact and in gaka then Ray with Lars
behind him in a sling you'll notice
maybe after his hand froze off he laain
inadem The Parables tell of an
unimaginable evil commanding an Army of
Ghosts I find this line to be a little
odd especially for someone like Ray who
knows the scripture chapter in verse
Parables refer to short simple stories
that are used to explain moral lessons
like the prodical son like you wouldn't
have Parables for telling doomsday
imagery like this you find this kind of
stuff in the Book of Revelation the
verses of Rich Ray probably would not
call Parables so maybe he's referring to
some other non-biblical text that is
known as like Parables like the Dead Sea
Scrolls have a section of parables
everything's just Doom and Gloom and end
of world prophecy Ry explains that this
Army has a power to kill with fear
itself and Gary explains it as scared to
death it seems like the idea of this
movie is a play on the old Franklin D
Roosevelt Maxum the only thing we have
to fear is fear itself and these ghosts
cause death by draining the warmth that
humans associate with safety and that
fear is what freezes them dead in their
tracks the leader of this Army is a
slender figure with Longhorns named gaka
according to a Funko Pop release gaka is
depicted on this ancient tablet with fog
bill out from behind her arms I'm
referring to this ghost as her as
actress Emily Allen Lind has been cast
in an undisclosed role I don't know if
it's this or some other part that we
just haven't seen yet in trailers I like
this shot of graa spiny fingers latching
onto horns that are held on display
against this gold wall I actually think
this might be the fancy fancy location
that we see the firefighter in later
when he touches a frozen body and it
shatters I'm wondering if that is some
kind of old Museum or like an old house
where gak's horns were kept his art
pieces also it looks like this
firefighter is from fir housee number
eight which is the station that the
Ghostbusters repurpose for their office
so I think the idea of this movie is
that the first Ice Age might have been
caused by gaka and that only by
defeating gaka were tribes of early
humans able to flourish into
civilizations that's why it's called
Frozen Empire is that during the Ice Age
this Supernatural force is really what
was ruling the planet I'm guessing gaco
was defeated in ancient times by
severing the horns and then trapping its
depowered form in the orb like this orb
was an oldw World version of the trap
device and we might learn about ancient
Sorcerers who busted ghosts in their own
ways we see a blizzard storm cloud
approaching Coney Island beach with
spikes that shoot up from the sand and
then throughout the city honestly it's
less the cold that I would be worried
about in the way that The Day After
Tomorrow froze fleeing civilians who
couldn't run fast enough but I would
just be more worried about getting
impaled on one of these spikes like
notice how this huge Spike goes up
through the taxi and it looks like it
goes up on the driver's side if there
was anybody in that taxi they would be
dead Winston is bringing the old gang
back together let's get to
work can I be of any help melet in
uniform yeah yes Janine even gets to
suit up in this movie and it looks like
it's Janine there who has this wrist
Mount ATT Tech that looks like a wand
free Neutron we see a library Ghost
charging at Ray a call back to the
library ghost at the beginning of the
1984 film but this actually might be in
his occult Bookshop if so the Deep
Stacks in the store suggests that this
is a way bigger collection in floor
space than I would expect Ray to have
and I like how this Library ghost at
least looks like parts of her were made
practically because back in that 1984
film she was made pretty much completely
practically and she looks great then we
also meet this new Little Ghost who
projectile vomits green slime this guy
is apparently called pukey and we hear
Paul rud referencing the lyrics of the
Ray Parker Jr theme song is there's
something strange is there's something
weird what are people going to call and
yes he's quoting the often joked about
lyric from Ray Parker Jr can I tell you
something else buston makes me feel good
makes me feel good yes buston makes us
all feel good but you know what it's
that second follow-up defensive it makes
me feel good that I love about Paul
Red's delivery here like the line isn't
gross in his mind he just kind of
wholesomely loves the life of a
Ghostbuster we see the New York Public
Library the lion statues these are
actually named patience and fortitude
and these guys appeared in the 1984 film
after Ray Egon and Peter left the
library but the lion statue comes to
life and Roars at Ray and Dr Hubert now
maybe I'm overthinking it but think
about the new younger comedic actors
that are now part of this franchise Paul
Rudd Pat Oswalt James acter and C Nani
doesn't it kind of seem like we're
getting a new Ghostbusters lineup for
this generation with those four guys
like Paul Rudd would be like the Bill
Murray Peter bankman type Paton Oswalt
would be the nerdy bookish Dan akroy
race stance type James acter would be
the brainy engineer Egon spinkler type
and Kam Nani is kind of the outsider who
comes into this world loving it even
more than the others now I guess I don't
completely agree with those actors
fitting those personality types
completely perfectly like really in my
opinion C's comedic energy is more
Venkman Paul rud is more of a Winston
and patton ell would be as much of a
Spangler as acter is but I guess I'm
just trying to see this from the way
Sony would try to package these actors
and sell them to International audiences
and if this movie is successful they're
totally going to want a new Ghostbusters
lineup of funny men from 2024 that
doesn't include aging actors and doesn't
include kids and doesn't remind people
of the 2016 lineup lucky Domingo fires
the proton pack at gaka as gaka Towers
over the lab but notice that gaka here
does not have the horns yet so this
would be earlier in the movie before
they reach their final form but also
notice that that proton stream itself
freezes so an energy stream freezing
whoo now some trailer shots showed
Lucky's eye freezing over but later
shots with the full cast do show lucky
with the rest of them so I assume lucky
is going to recover but but it also
seems like this basement lab is going to
be the location of the final showdown
with the combined generations of
Ghostbuster teams heads up call dark and
horny at 12:00 now notice that all
characters are visible in frame for this
group shot of gara's ice vomit forming a
trench but on the far left that is
definitely an additional character that
is not one of the others running off to
the side so did they do it did they get
Lewis Tully Rick Moranis to come out of
retirement for this movie Rick morina
said in the year 2000 that he was like
done being in movies he was just going
to go play his banjo over rest of his
light and be happy which I was always
happy for him that he did that but then
like around 2020 he said that he was
going to come back in movies to make a
honey Shunk the kids reboot called
shrunk with director Joe Johnston that
was speculated to be a Disney plus
release but we haven't heard anything
about it guys we might finally get a
Rick Moranis comeback and if this gets
us one step closer to having an STV
reunion with Katherine O'Hara Eugene
Levy Marty Short oh my god dream come
true so we end this trailer in the
firehouse attic as Trevor approaches a
pile of rappers a massive pile of
rappers with the the Trap and blast
Simer burst out passing through him
leaving a trail of ectoplasm in his
mouth I assume Trevor just had his mouth
open inconveniently because Peter
bankman did also spit up a bit of
ectoplasm in the hotel but I just wonder
when Slimer phases through something is
it just like any open Orphus can catch
some of the Slime or as he goes through
your mouth and through your lungs and
everything can some of the Slime get
trapped in there too like how much slime
is in them okay here's my soapbox rant
when it comes to resurrecting dead
actors Harold RIS and Ghostbusters
afterlife Carrie fish and the rise of
Skywalker Christopher ree in the flash
it may piss some of you guys off if you
loved the ending of Ghostbusters
afterlife and you know what as I watched
it I appreciated it too but just hear me
out on this even if a deceased actor's
living relatives or their estate gives
their blessing or if it's the late
actor's friends involved in the making
of the new installment I still do not
think that is enough we never know what
relationship an actor had with their
relatives they might have never met
their grandkids or their great grandkids
they might consider their future
descendants total for trying to
cash in on great great grand Grandpa's
work with royalties paid to the Family
Estate so I just think unless the actor
wrote down somewhere that they consented
to their digital likeness being used to
zombie them in a future sequel or future
franchise connected project or if that
actor had consented to their living
descendants controlling how their
digital likeness gets zombified if we
don't know otherwise I just think it's
unethical to do it like if you want to
bring a character back hire a new actor
who looks like them or film them in a
way that doesn't have to show their face
or have to digitally recreate them in
any weird way and if it feels
disrespectful to do that with an actor
it should feel even worse to do it with
bfx that's just my opinion now in this
case OG Ghostbusters actors did joke
about them being brought back in Future
sequels as ghosts but I don't think they
meant postmortem as was the case with
Harold RIS I don't know maybe they did
discuss it internally but are we just
going to take Jason wman and Ivan
wrightman's word for that are we going
to say it's enough that Harold Ramos's
family said it was okay I don't know
guys with these movies I just feel like
Sony is seeing a nostalgic cash grab and
then other Studios saw Ghostbusters
afterlife and we're like hey we can can
do this with Christopher Reed I just
think it's an icky precedent and I don't
think the new sag rule goes far enough
but let me know down below your thoughts
on this issue and what from this trailer
has you the most excited another
reminder to join us for our live show in
Los Angeles on February 15th and give
this video a like And subscribe to new
rock stars I'm Eric Boss thanks for
watching see you next time
bye